vous l'avez compris les dirigeants de
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord ont donc en rien message lors de ce
sommet annuel pour affronter je cite les
nouveaux défis posés par la russie et la
chine
c'était le souhait du président
américain joe biden
les alliés l'ont exaucé mais les
intérêts américains sont-ils les mêmes
que ceux des pays du vieux continent
l'otan est elle une alliance encore
pertinentes pour les européens français
en tête c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre à nous
sommes avec régis chamagne ancien
colonel de l'armée de l'air à ses côtés
françois chauvancy général de brigade
expert en géostratégie bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france une citation pour commencer dans
ce débat tant que la russie ne montre
pas qu'elle respectait le droit
international et qu'elle honore ses
obligations et responsabilités
internationales il ne peut y avoir de
retour à la normale c'est
l'avertissement conclusions du sommet
c'est la recherche d'un ennemi
comment se souvient d'une petite phrase
en 1987 ans j'ai fait mes recherches je
suis retombé sur cette phrase assez
parlante c'est un conseiller de
gorbatchev qui a dansé aux occidentaux
nous allons vous rendre le pire des
services vous priver d'un ennemi c'est
la recherche aujourd'hui de cet ennemi
commun clairement françois chambon si
non je ne le pense pas je dis simplement
que l'auteur met en garde elle prévient
l annonce
elle entre dans un jeu de coopération
entre 30 et à illies a effectivement une
entre guillemets une menace sécuritaire
sur l'europe de l'ouest
rumba aujourd'hui effectivement dans un
conseil comme un sommet qui vient
d'avoir lieu
il est difficile pour les états membres
de ne pas désigner quelqu'un ou un état
qui effectivement depuis quelques années
depuis 2014
depuis la crimée montre une certaine
certaines velléités de puissance donc
l'auto est une alliance défensive
militaire j'ai bien dit défensive
donc il est normal qu'elle s'exprime sur
un point
sans forcément faire de la russie
l'ennemi premier l'ennemi réel mais
c'est une mise en garde en tout cas
clairement le but affiché était de
resserrer en ces alliances pour contrer
ces on les appelle comme on veut les
ennemis les rivaux la chine la russie
pourquoi est-ce aussi important chez
régis chamagne
de se défendre entre guillemets de la
russie c'est important pour les états
unis l'otan est une organisation sous
leadership américain
depuis le début il faut bien considérer
que les autres pays de l'otan sont des
vassaux et cela se retrouve dans les
structures de commandement et dans tous
les postes importants qui sont occupées
au sein de la chaîne de commandement de
l'otan les postes importants sont
occupés par des officiers américains et
les autres sont des des vassaux et
normalement l'otan aurait dû disparaître
après la chute de l'urss
puisque l'otan a été créée en 1949 pour
faire face à une attaque potentielle de
libérer 16 contre un des pays du monde
occidental du monde libre donc comme on
disait à l'époque et après la chute de
l'urss l'otan n'avait plus sa raison
d'être
je me souviens avoir participé à un
stage de l'otan en janvier 90 m
robert hamer gao une station annonce ans
ou dans les apple d'allemandes et à
l'époque il y avait véritablement une
crise dans l'otan parce qu'elle ils se
cherchaient des démissions de nouvelles
missions il y avait une crise
existentielle de l'otan et tous les
officiers de l'otan était perdue
les écarts pleine crise existentielle il
se disait nous devons continuer à
exister parce que notre organisation
fonctionne oui mais c'est pas une raison
aussi la productivité y'a pas de raison
de la conserver et du coup d'autant
c'est senna pu comme toute structure qui
cherche à se maintenir en vie elle s'est
cherché d'autres missions et plus
seulement défensive mais offensive
également puisqu'elle était intervenu en
afghanistan on peut pas dire que
l'afghanistan de menaces les pays
d'europe et
les états unis ou le canada donc je
pense que la ja on est dans un on est
dans une situation où les états unis à
travers l'otan maintienne une
vassalisation militaires sur les pays
occidentaux et nous enfin en tout cas
nous français si nous nous positionnons
par rapport à l'histoire à la longue
histoire de france nous n'avons aucun
intérêt à rester dans cette organisation
est vraiment et beaucoup de pays
européens comme nous n'ont aucun intérêt
mais et se trouve qu'au cours des trente
quarante dernières années il ya eu un
changement dans je viens pour la
politique d' influence américaine pour
l'europe et en particulier en france a
été très efficace ce qui a mené à aux
élections de nicolas sarkozy de françois
hollande et d'emmanuel macro qui sont
complètement dans les petits toutous de
les américains abandonnaient de
connaître son opinion sur ce que vous
venez de nous dire aucun intérêt en tout
cas pour vous des pays européens et
notamment la france a de rester dans
l'otan va justement écouter l'américain
en chef le président joe biden
ce matin avant donc cette réunion
depuis quelques années on voit de plus
en plus que nous avons de nouveaux défis
à relever et nous avons la russie qui
n'agit pas d'une manière conforme à ce
que nous avions espéré tout comme la
chine il vient de répondre à régis à
magnin président américain le défi c'est
évidemment la russie et la chine où une
raison d'être et d'exister pour pour
l'otan françois chanson ou alors d'avant
jouets réagir à ce qui est dit régis
chamagne parce qu'il faut quand même pas
exagérer que les américains est une
certaine mainmise sur l'otan c'est
indéniable mais que nous n'ayons pas les
potes commandement à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités c'est un peu faux il ya
deux grands postes de commandement un
tenu par un américain sept jours et un
tenus par les français à norfolk bon
deux postes 50 % pour la france je pense
quand même d'une certaine forme de
répartition à peu près équitable à notre
bénéfice
deuxième point qu'elles sont d'état
n'aurait pas intérêt à rester dans
l'otan je n'y crois pas il suffit de
regarder chaque fois que la france
propose une certaine c'est un dégagement
de l'otan à chaque fois la grande
majorité des états de l'europe de l'otan
disent non on reste parce que les
américains par leur puissance militaire
sont une garantie et puis n'y a pas que
cela
les américains ont quand même certaines
tendances à savoir décider à savoir agir
ce qui dans une europe à 26 ou à 28
n'est pas tout à fait possible il ya
toujours une raison pour ne pas agir
finalement les américains sont des
agitateurs entre guillemets de la prise
de décision voilà alors maintenant
effectivement pour revenir à la russie
et à la chine
je pense pas que la russie soit
considéré comme une menace principale de
l'europe
la seule différence c'est qu'à talent
elle est à la frontière comme est à la
frontière
ça bouge il ya le pôle de l'ukraine
comme n'avait pas évoqué qui est quand
même un sujet important
donc il faut pas oublier l'ukraine et
puis surtout il ya une vraie réalité
la chine est une menace aujourd'hui est
d'ailleurs gira même que la russie
devrait s'inquiéter
la chine est une menace elle est une
menace pas forcément militaire la date
d'aujourd'hui
aastra sandalettes une menace économique
à l'etna
influence et à ce titre là on peut
comprendre que l'otan s'en préoccupent
maintenant pour agir aussi encore régis
chamagne qui dit qui évoque
effectivement le besoin de se trouver un
ennemi d'ailleurs la question de la
déposer tout à l'heure non une réalité
l'otan est une alliance vivante c'est
une alliance vivant qui évoluent là nous
sommes dans l'écriture finalement du
concept stratégique 2030 il ne faut pas
l'oublier
les orientations ont été données en 2019
il est normal que toute alliance
militaire car c'est une alliance
militaire défensive évolué et estiment
les menaces à venir et je crois que
c'est là le rôle de l'otan
donc le temps est utile pour ça ça ne
veut pas dire préparer la guerre c'est
simplement faire ce qu'il faut pour
qu'elle n'arrive pas et je crois que
tous les adversaires potentiels qui
puisse exister à court ou à moyen terme
sinon à long terme d'un vent prendre
conscience en tout cas beaucoup disent
que l'otan s'est un peu éloigné de son
but originel
on l'écouté je pense que l'otan
aujourd'hui est dans une situation qui
nécessite une très grande clarification
stratégique
l'otan a été construit pour faire face
au pacte de varsovie
elle s'est structurée idéologiquement
dans ce face à face il n'est plus on a
besoin de dire qui est notre ennemi et
où la chine n'est pas dans la géographie
atlantique ou alors ma carte à un
problème résiste chaman clairement
l'otan besoin d'une clarification
stratégique aujourd'hui
alors d'abord je voudrais dire que
l'otan ne sais pas quand mais contre le
pacte de l'arceau me laisser le
contraire
le temps était créée en 1949 le pacte de
varsovie en 1955 56 donc emmanuel macron
et un problème avec l'histoire
s'agissant des postes de commandement je
voudrais répond qu'on avait acheté aux
anciens et dire que le poste de norfolk
n'est pas dans la chaîne opérationnelle
c'est le potentiel qu au moment de la
transformation et j'ai parlé de
commandement opérationnel au début juste
ça ensuite votre question je veux je
vais devoir
emmanuel macron dit clairement que
l'otan besoin aujourd'hui d'une
clarification stratégique en clair on
s'est un petit peu éloigné du but
originel est ce que vous partagez ce
diagnostic du président français oui on
s'en est tellement éloignés que comme je
le dis au départ l'otan mais à mon sens
une raison d'être
ce sont des à travers l'otan à travers
les buts stratégiques et les
orientations stratégiques de l'otan ce
sont les intérêts des états unis qui
parle est évidemment aujourd'hui les
états unis sentent bien que la russie
est la première puissance militaire au
monde
le pôle vue qualitatif donc ils sont
dépassés la chique je parle bien d'un
point de vue qualitatif à la première
puissance militaire du monde
les dernières les derniers matériels
néerlandais avait développé par la
russie sont très largement supérieur au
matériel américain f-35 était une en
échec absolu et tous les derniers
développements américains sont mauvais
pour actuellement la chine la russie et
la première puissance militaire au monde
d'après du qualitatif et la chine monte
en puissance et l'air froid mon avis
encore loin d'y arriver mais elle
présentait une menace
je ne suis pas certain que l'on puisse
considérer que des pays qui se
développent des grands pays qui se
développent constitue une menace
ça c'est la vision américaine la vision
d'une amérique qui veut dominer le monde
et être la seule puissance dominant le
monde effectivement qui considère que
quand un géant comme la chine ou comme
la russie se redresse ça constitue une
menace
de mon point de vue ça n'en constitue
pas la chine
effectivement à de gros potentiel mais
elle a énormément de grands actes et là
également je veux dire de grande
fragilité comme par exemple sa capacité
à nourrir sa population
l'autosuffisance de la chine en matière
de nourriture par la suffisance de la
chine en matière de nourriture est aux
alentours de 60% donc zappé très fragile
sur certains dans certains domaines et
considérer que ce free
sous prétexte qu'il se relève serait
qu'une menace est à mon avis une grande
erreur de jugement
nous sommes liés au lieu de disputer
avec ces pays plutôt que de les
considérer comme de potentiels ennemi
françois chauvancy est ce que ce n'est
pas un petit peu l'échec les européens
finalement au faux l'otan on sait que
emmanuel macron le premier rêver d'une
grande europe de la défense qui a bien
du mal à voir le jour
oui c'est ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure quand on a 30 et adam une
alliance dont le canada et les états
unis
il est certain que mettre tout le monde
d'accord c'est difficile bon maintenant
pour revenir sur la question de la
menace chinoise
pour l'instant les actions je dirais
militarisé hanche en mer de chine
méridionale pose problème aujourd'hui de
jour en jour de semaine en semaine
y compris pour les forces françaises des
forces navales il y à des risques
d'affrontement
et il faut bien en prendre conscience
alors dire que la chine n'est pas une
menace
dès lors qu'elle a des ambitions
territoriales y compris maritime
je ne doute je pense qu'il faut appeler
ça une menace maintenant la question
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure elle
peut-être beaucoup plus importante
la question est celle et georges
d'ailleurs registre chaman sur ce point
là quelles sont les limites de l'otan
jusqu'à ou devons-nous aller en terme
d'intervention nous sommes allés en
afghanistan s'était pas franchement le
but eut traité de l'alliance
d'atlantique nord
nous y sommes allés maintenant il faut
de se demander pourquoi on en est on y
est allé effectivement une influence
américaine une influence aussi en partie
les ans les français ont abondé dans ce
sens il ya comme une réaction y penser
là je reviens à votre question à vous la
défense de l'europe pose problème
aujourd'hui et nous n'arrivons pas à
créer une vraie défense européenne
l'union européenne est incapable d'avoir
une défense commune pour plein de
raisons différentes
en revanche l'otan est le seul organisme
militaire dans lequel effectivement tout
et nation trouvent leur place plus ou
moins importante en fonction du budget
en fonction des compétences et autres
donc l'otan et pour ça un outil
irremplaçable non pas parce que c'est le
meilleur mais simplement parce qu'il
existe et qu'il a fait ses preuves
effectivement 1949 il à empêcher la
guerre en
et pour l'instant effectivement on
évolue vers d'autres missions peut-être
d'ailleurs à des évolutions du traité
dont on ne parle jamais et là je
rejoindrai ce qui a été dit sur la chine
ce qui a été dit sur l'afghanistan il ya
un moment où s'arrête le temps moi j'ai
interpellé de ça d'une manière positive
l'otan aujourd'hui est nécessaire
simplement parce qu'elles assurent la
sécurité des états européens en y
associant notamment les états unis
merci en tout cas tous les deux et
françois changement si régis chaman
d'avoir été avec nous pour débattre de
la nécessité de l'utilité de cette
organisation atlantique merci à vous et
je